an absolute genius man management just
an incredible guy Bob Dobbs was helping
me a lot every day I think was he was a
motivator it was a man capable of
bringing to his groups his happiness
[Music]
he was brought up to work very hard but
to respect and to understand there was
nothing ever put on a plate for Bobby
when he was a youngster I was under his
tutelage for 14 years as a player it's
just a football club and with England as
well and that helped to make me a man
and more so than an actual football
player so just an incredible guy he was
such a passionate man the message was
clear and always be positive he was like
a father
I think Barcelona was my was my best
season I think the relationship between
Bobby and Gaza was was the extraordinary
many ways it was like a father and son
but a very frustrated father a lot of
the time we all had a love for Bobby
well out well love for him I didn't want
to let him down and Gaza was like that
Gaz I saw him very much as a as a father
figure but we all we all did but he only
didn't want to let him down the guy that
could have done anything to spend most
of his name worrying about me
I think he was very good at hiding his
emotions no question bobby was a fighter
I mean right right throughout his life
in many ways right to the end of course
and that was more than demonstrated in
certainly nice managerial career on
numerous occasions for me clearly much
more than than my boss meant to say that
he was my boss and for me was much more
than
I'm very proud of the part of his life
of his legacy we all owe him so much in
terms of memories in terms of the way
that the way that we played and the way
that he went about his work as well is
just just fantastic memories and is
they'll never be repeated
[Music]
[Music]